1999's The Mummy blew audiences away
with its blend of high-octane action and
chilling horror. But what has the cast been up
to in the two decades since the film's release?
We're here to catch you upon the
goings-on of The Mummy's cast,
from the Oscars they've won to
the challenges they've faced.
Brendan Fraser plays the lead role of Rick
O’Connell, a rugged adventurer who leads an
expedition to Hamunaptra , the city of the dead
where the high priest Imhotep’s corpse resides.
When it turns out that the terrifying
legends about this mysterious city are true,
his travels take a deadly turn.
Initially, Fraser found continued success in
the sequels The Mummy Returns, and The Mummy:
Tomb of the Dragon Emperor. He also starred
in a remake of the 1967 film Bedazzled,
Looney Tunes: Back in Action,
and the Oscar-winning film Crash.
However, after being assaulted in 2003, losing
his mother, and going through a bitter divorce,
the star took it upon himself
to leave Hollywood behind.
Fraser told GQ Magazine:
“I bought into the pressure that comes
[…] with a professional life that’s
being molded and shaped and guided and
managed. That requires what they call a
thick skin. […] I just felt I couldn’t be a
part of it. I didn’t feel that I belonged.”
In recent years though, Fraser has
made a modest return to the industry.
You may have spotted him in
series such as Trust, Condor,
or Doom Patrol, where he provides his own
idiosyncratic take on the DC Comics hero Robotman.
After reading aloud from the ancient Book of
the Dead, librarian and aspiring Egyptologist
Evelyn Carnahan unintentionally wakes
up Imhotep from his eternal slumber.
Played by Rachel Weisz , Carnahan
must fight to survive as the undead
high priest strives to sacrifice her in
order to resurrect his long-dead lover.
Following the success of The Mummy and The Mummy
Returns, Weisz went on to build an impressive
film career for herself. In addition to winning
an Oscar for her role in The Constant Gardener,
she also starred in numerous other highly
regarded films, such as The Lobster,
The Favourite, and The Light Between Oceans.
Her personal life has been just as busy.
After spending a number of years
being married to renowned director
Darren Aronofsky , she got hitched to
Daniel Craig and became a mother of two.
John Hannah plays Evelyn’s brother, Jonathan
Carnahan, who sets the story in motion by giving
her a map to Hamunaptra. After confessing that he
stole it from Rick, who has since been imprisoned,
the two set off to free him and enlist him to
travel with them to the ancient city of the dead.
After starring in The Mummy trilogy,
Hannah focused more on television,
where he became a regular on
numerous series, including Carnivale,
Trust Me, and Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. However,
he made appearances in a few films as well,
The Hurricane and Ghost Son being two that
he has claimed to be particularly fond of.
His newest endeavors include the sci-fi comedy,
The Intergalactic Adventures of Max
Cloud, and The Auschwitz Report.
Patricia Velasquez plays Anck-su-namun , Imhotep’s
illicit lover and Pharaoh Seti’s mistress.
After having an affair behind the Pharaoh's
back, and subsequently killing him in
order to keep their secret, they both face
fatal consequences that echo through time.
Velasquez has continued her
acting career since The Mummy,
starring in TV series like Arrested Development,
American Family, and the L Word. She also played
the role of Patricia Alvarez in the
horror film The Curse of La Llorona .
Outside of Hollywood, Velasquez is also a
committed activist. In 2002, she founded the
Wayuu Taya Foundation, which works to support
indigenous communities in Latin America.
She also published an autobiography,
Straight Walk, in 2015,
in which she officially came out as a lesbian.
In the book, she writes:
“As my daughter started growing up and I
was teaching her to be honest and proud,
I knew it was time for me to set an
example — which meant facing my truth.”
Arnold Vosloo plays the memorable and
terrifying Imhotep, who not only wipes
out a group of treasure hunters, but also
brings back the ten plagues of ancient Egypt.
Though he starred in the sequel, The Mummy
Returns, he did not reprise his role in
the final installment of the trilogy,
Tomb of the Dragon Emperor. However,
he did go on to act in many other films
and TV series, including 24, G.I. Joe:
The Rise of Cobra, G.I. Joe: Retaliation,
Blood Diamond, and Tom Clancy’s Jack Ryan.
He is also a prolific voice
actor, having appeared in
everything from All-Star Superman
to Voltron: Legendary Defender.
Jonathan Hyde plays Dr. Allen Chamberlain, who
hopes to strike it rich on his expedition to
Egypt. Traveling with a group
of treasure hunters to Cairo,
he opens a chest that contains the
Book of the Dead. Because of this,
he is marked with the curse of Imhotep,
who consumes his life energy, killing him.
Since The Mummy, he has appeared in films
such as Land of the Blind and Crimson Peak,
and TV series such as The Strain
and Trollhunters: Tales of Arcadia.
He also has many theatre accolades, including
roles in King Lear, Peter Pan, and Julias Caesar.
His most recent theater work was
his performance as Richard Nixon
in Frost/Nixon at the Sheffield Crucible Theater.
Kevin J. O’Connor plays Beni Gabor , a
selfish treasure hunter who’s willing to use
anyone in order to come out on top. This mindset
leads him to swear his devotion to Imhotep,
and ultimately ends up
ensuring his untimely demise.
Besides playing Beni, O’Connor is likely best
known for his roles as Igor in Van Helsing
and Henry in There Will Be Blood. He’s also been
involved in the Stephen King mini-series 11.22.63,
the television adaptation of Joseph Heller’s Catch
22, and On Becoming a God in Central Florida.
Oded Fehr
Oded Fehr plays the fierce warrior, Ardeth
Bay, who leads the Medjai in Hamunaptra.
The Medjai are descendants of Pharaoh Seti’s
palace guards, who guard Imhotep’s tomb.
Though Ardeth warns the explorers to leave,
they choose not to heed his warnings.
Consequently, they must turn to him
for help after Imhotep is resurrected.
[The Mummy 01:41:57 - Ardeth cocks his shotgun]
In addition to The Mummy, Fehr has starred
in Deuce Bigalow: Male Gigolo, and three
Resident Evil movies — specifically Apocalypse,
Extinction, and Retribution. He has also landed
regular roles in several series including The
First, When Heroes Fly, and Once Upon a Time.
He married producer Rhonda Tollefson in
2000, and has three children with her.
Erick Avari plays Dr. Terrence Bey,
Evelyn’s boss and curator of the Cairo
Museum of Antiquities. Later in the film,
we find out that he's actually working with the
Medjai to prevent Imhotep from being resurrected.
You may otherwise know him best as Cecil
Anderson in the 2002 comedy, Mr. Deeds,
or as Tival in the 2001 remake of Planet of
the Apes. He's also taken on roles in numerous
TV series, such as Heroes, The Middleman,
Leverage, Hung, The Brink, and The Chosen.
In 2015, he made his directorial debut with the
film, Chasing Eagle Rock. He’s even worked as a
voice actor, most prominently portraying Master
Rahool in the Destiny series of video games.
Stephen Dunham plays Dr. Henderson,
a gentleman who tags along with the
treasure hunters in hopes of becoming
rich. As we've already recalled,
things don't end well for them after they open
the chest that contains the Book of the Dead.
His most prominent work besides The Mummy was
his supporting role in the 2008 comedy Get Smart,
and for playing Dr. Chamberlain in Monster-in-Law.
He also acted in TV series
such as DAG and Oh, Grow Up.
His role in Paranormal Activity 4
ended up being his last acting gig,
as he sadly passed away from a
heart attack at the age of 48.
Corey Johnson plays Mr. Daniels, another member
of the ill-fated treasure hunting troupe.
Despite his swift end in The Mummy, he's
consistently proved his staying power as an actor,
with roles in blockbusters such as The
Bourne Ultimatum, Captain Phillips,
and Ex Machina. Like numerous others in
The Mummy cast, he has dabbled in theater.
His most notable accolade is his performance
as Mitch in A Streetcar Named Desire.
Johnson's newest endeavors include roles
in the short film Swept Under the Rug,
and the full-length feature Morbius.
Lastly, Tuc Watkins plays Mr. Burns —
another member of the treasure hunter
troupe who fails to escape the curse of
Imhotep once the ancient chest is opened.
He's best known for his role as
David Vickers on the soap opera,
One Life to Live, and also his role
as Bob Hunter on Desperate Housewives.
If that’s not your cup of tea, you can find him
on the mystery web series Where the Bears Are,
or on the second season of the
dark comedy series Black Monday.
In 2013, he came out as
gay on an episode of Marie,
and announced that he'd become the
father of twins, via a surrogate.
He recalled his thoughts when he was much younger:
“I knew I was gay, and I knew
one day I was going to be a dad.”
Though The Mummy was released to mixed reviews
in 1999, it has surely become a movie that all
of us remember fondly. It was the epitome of a
summer blockbuster: incredible action sequences,
spooky curses, and the triumph of good over
evil. But beyond just being a fun movie,
The Mummy helped pave the way for
many subsequent action movies,
while simultaneously taking cues from
the much older films that influenced it.
It’s a classic, and we have no doubt that it
will continue to be for many years to come.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one